what's good to start with a black screen
now sometimes there is a question
they've really hadn't got the lights
here so I'm going to be mostly in
darkness like the screen sometimes
there's a question of what are my talks
about it's not always obvious from the
title today I chose something different
it's blindingly obvious what this is
about it's about procedural programming
the curious thing is why am I talking
about procedural programming surely it's
it's gone it's dead and we should be
talking about functional programming and
and next generational object-oriented
programming and so on
because it's dead well I'm here to tell
you that it's not I'm also here to tell
you that it's playing an important role
in a number of other paradigms and that
we actually lost out an awful lot of
stuff there's a lot of stuff in classic
procedural programming and it's
organizing model primarily structured
programming that people think they know
but they don't actually know okay so I
want to explore that as we go through
and things about me I edited this book a
few years ago because I'm very much
interested in code but I'm also
interested in a way that people do
things and the way that architectures
emerge and the experience is in fact
almost to the point of this talk there
is this idea that patterns to quote
Brian foot a blatant disregard for
originality okay the whole idea is that
we know stuff we know stuff already
we're just not very good at remembering
that we know stuff or looking around our
own history to discover that most of the
things that we talk about have actually
been solved it's not that we all knew
everything all of the time as it turns
out in the heart of procedural we
actually find an awful lot of stuff that
people are getting very excited by these
days and dates back quite away so
procedural when we normally think of
procedural we normally think old stuff
big slabs monolithic this is a
photograph I took earlier this year
because my wife and I are clearly very
romantic
this was taken on Valentine's Day we
grab the kids it's just that what should
we do it's Valentine's Day let's get
kind of romantic yeah let's take the
kids to go and see Stonehenge
they were quite impressed they'd seen
photographs of it and you know they were
both quite actually there are a lot
bigger than we expected that you know
even once you've seen the photographs
now as with any presentation I'm going
to have to leave some stuff out because
there's a huge wealth or what I could be
talking about and there is an art to
leaving stuff out you may wonder where
are all the tourists if you've ever has
anybody actually been to Stonehenge okay
where are all the tourists they're all
the way over there that's the art of
taking a good photograph you show the
bleakness of Salisbury Plain but when
people look at this stuff
what do they see they see monoliths
monolith oz the Greek for one stone one
big stone this is what you see when you
go into legacy code you see these large
difficult to move stones and you
theorize how was it that ancient
primitive people were able to put
together this code base okay how did
they do this how did you get so many
people to organize these monoliths and
everybody these days it's like oh no I'm
good
we've reorganized the stones you know
hey we've got microservices yeah we're
good yeah let me show you microservice
architecture this is what's actually
happening none of this stuff is new I
mean everybody's trying the same things
all of the time Doug McIlroy in the
1970s writing about the UNIX philosophy
captured an essence that we are trying
to recapture with every passing paradigm
and which started in the 1960s the UNIX
philosophy write programs that do one
thing and do it well write programs to
work together there's two parts to it
people normally remember one part yeah
yeah oh I've got something doing one
thing well it doesn't seem to fit with
anything else let's just add some code
to it that is the decay that you saw
okay it has been said that every program
starts rococo and then becomes rubble
there's two parts to this and this is
something we're gonna revisit later
there is a kind of mirror
here but I want to take you back to the
1960s I just referred to the 1960s
there's a lot of glorious stuff that
happened in the 1960s 1960s was a time
of change and we think it's the time of
change but there are some things in the
1960s that are still with us okay some
things just don't change I've got the
wrong stones they are against the odds
still with us
okay we have the fear of nuclear
holocaust
I thought that was done but no it's back
it's a revival movement the idea I grew
up during the Cold War and it's just
like I was glad to see the back of that
you know this whole imminent fear of
this stuff I'm now teaching it to my
kids so something I feel I can pass on
and what else to the 1960s bring that we
also still have me [ __ ] that's me okay
yeah if you doubt the ear I just look at
the clothes right so the 1960s what else
happened in the 1960s software
engineering happened in the 1960s the
classic NATO conference in garmisch in
1968 now a lot of people think that this
meeting was where the term software
engineering was coined well clearly it
wasn't because they put it you know he
was already called this by the time
people got there
1968 this was actually coined the term
software engineer who's coined by
Margaret Hamilton who wrote the who led
the team that wrote the Apollo guidance
software so this is all happening in the
nineteen mid 1960s she wrote this and
she coined the term software engineering
she felt that the people that did the
software we're getting looked down upon
and they used a number of different
language the key language they used was
language called Mack the MIT algebraic
compiler and it was hand compiled if
you're wondering what's hand compiled
mean it is exactly as it sounds human
beings looking at the code because
that's the only way you can trust that
you're gonna get the right stuff you
can't trust automation yeah we have
moved on a bit since then but people
would kind of take the code and turn it
into
and turn it into assembler and then you
have people cross-checking it so that
level that hasn't changed we've got into
this idea that maybe you check somebody
else's work so she was responsible for
this 1968 was a great year because 2001
a Space Odyssey came out one of my
favorite films and it anticipated the
moon landings it's it was it was quite
ahead of the curve now the key thing
here is I want to observe is the use of
typeface
this is guild songs which is a beautiful
typeface and very very strongly
influenced he was developed within a
year 1928 1927 was Futura I used to
think this was guild songs but I did a
quick check the Gees are different and
it's logical future this is in Germany
future as a German font Gil songs is a
British film so the typography of the
1960s is glorious and beautiful and it's
not something we should throw away
there's also some wisdom in here I'm not
going to say that we knew everything
back in the 1960s but it turns out that
more people had the right idea than we
give them credit for
when people think software engineering
and they think this conference they
think oh it's just about - it's it's all
about procedural programming formal
proofs and waterfowl development process
Andy Kinsler the design process is an
iterative one okay it's not the only
point in the document that says this and
so I find absolutely fascinating clearly
something happened after the 1960s some
people blame disco some people blame
flares I don't know kids they also had
great sense of humor and a great insight
to go with this sense of humor there are
two classes of system designers the
first if given five problems will solve
them one at a time the second will come
back and announce that these are the
real problems these are not the problems
you're looking for and will eventually
propose a solution to the single problem
which underlies the original five this
is the system type who is great during
the initial stage of a design project
however you better get rid of him after
the first six months if you want to get
a working system
we also see other points here Alan
Perlis the first recipient of the
cheering award a software system can
best be designed if the testing is
interlaced with the designing instead of
being used after the design now I'm
gonna put some code in because we're
talking 1968 here and before okay let's
let's get a little bit retro one of the
languages that came out around then
Algol 68 was a it was a fantastic effort
in terms of language design it was very
much ahead of its time people said they
couldn't implement it was not possible
to implement it it was too big and it
was too complex I've looked through the
language spec it is currently smaller
than the language spec for C in fact
pretty much any language you care to
name that you are using is larger than
this okay so our sense of what is large
and complex has changed but it
introduced of a really important
principle into the mainstream concept
language design and orthogonality the
idea to compose different features that
everything is in some way regular it had
some rather nice interesting ideas so
I'm going to calculate a leap year here
you could put space spaces we're not
significant you know identifier so is
leave here that's quite cute and we also
find if you've ever wondered where the
int keyword came from it was our loss
sixty-eight bull ultimately our loss
sixty-eight skip is basically pass in in
Python but obviously we're gonna start
off with a default false now I'm going
to do this in a kind of a test first
style because I was fascinated I wonder
if I can create a simple table driven
approach to just testing the leap year
logic using Algol 68
it's absolutely trivial it's lovely so I
got to create a proposition here
leap year spec years not divisible by
four not leap years and they notice what
I'm doing here is I'm passing what we
call a closure these days but was simply
an anonymous procedure it returns void
oh yes if you want to wear void came
from Algol 68 in other words if you are
using a program language today there is
a 90%
chance that you are using features that
originally came from our lore 68 but
I've never heard of Algol 68 you say
that's great like you never heard of
your great-grandfather it turns out that
you still have the genetic material as
do modern languages a certain art is
leap year in 1967 okay so what does that
look like Oh
structure came from there as well so
what we've got is mode it didn't like
the word type so they use mode of access
proposition is a name and a void
returning procedure that takes no
arguments so this is basically the way
at the end of the 60s and then also with
the Algol 68 report in 74 that was
refined to allow people to actually
implement it properly was the idea of
this is how you do procedural
programming this is the essence of
procedure program it is the procedure
you should be able to take procedures
and pass them around okay that is
fundamental to procedural programming a
lot of people got very excited about
higher order functions and first-class
objects recently it's kind of sweet if
they knew their history they might not
be quite so excited so so now I can go
ahead and I can do this and I can run a
test against it let's test the leap here
spec turns out the test function is here
anything I want to point out all those
of you who are using bourne shell and
it's derivatives like bash if you've
ever wondered about do and alt yet they
come from here didn't have dot notation
they used off instead but they did use
square brackets for a rave then we think
anything else there right so let's build
this one up so here's an interesting one
the whole of the body of my procedure is
actually an expression I don't need to
put a return in fact there is no
returning Algol will discover why in a
moment and I can just build this one up
okay assertion at a time and it's all
quite readable this all makes kind of
sense equals does mean equals
rather than equals equals so yeah this
is quite cute this is actually
surprisingly easy to write now there's a
couple of other things that we can do
here maybe I want to use more make this
more data-driven rather than just
passing in blocks of code to run I could
make it more data-driven so perhaps I
want to write something like this
years not visible by four not leap years
so with 20 17 2001 1967 and one expect
false and you see this is quite nice
slight change there and think types
resizable arrays one thing our loss
sixty-eight fortunately did not pass
onto most languages is that it is one
counting you can't your erase from one
I'm sure this makes Americans feel very
comfortable because they think that the
ground floor is the first floor whereas
everybody else knows that's not by one
error you count from the ground floor
zero one above ground two above ground
three above ground this makes us very
interesting international conversations
sometimes I'll meet you on the first
floor yeah yeah I'd never made a mistake
with that one okay so this the test
driver for this is a little more
involved I'm not going to go through it
in detail but I want to draw your
attention to some of those radical
features that people have thought of
more recent not the fact that there's a
statement there but the fact that
there's declarations after statements
the idea is that a declaration is his a
movable thing this is ultimately made
its way into C++ for which one of its
progenitors was indeed Algol 68 biana
was very strongly influenced by it what
else can you say yeah you can declare
anywhere including an if statement I've
noticed some go programmers got very
excited about this 1960s innovation
recently basically go was invented in
the 1970s every feature that go if you
think go is a modern minimal language it
was invented the 1970s it just took
three decades for somebody to actually
put a syntax to it go is effectively a
procedural language we find that it is
not particularly object-oriented it's
not particularly functional it might use
the word func but that's the influence
of the 1970s it's more a case that it's
more a case that it is a classically
procedural language in the Algol 68
tradition including its concurrency
model we'll come back to that a little
bit later what else can we put it oh yes
you've ever wonder where the compound
assignment comes from it comes from
Algol 68 although we obviously dropped
the colon after awhile in line with the
the equals four assignment
and this whole point is that statements
and expressions are interchangeable
there is no concept of difference here
so I can easily have an expression that
is conditional that contains loops
there's also a shorthand which is
actually curiously enough probably
slightly more elegant than the Elvis
operator that we find in sea influenced
languages although I still quite like
the fact that we can use if and else to
make it more explicit so there's a lot
of stuff going on here which i think is
absolutely fascinating a lot of people
don't realize this is how procedural
programming was supposed to evolve I'm
not gonna make it claim by the way that
this is when test-first development was
developed that was that was the 1970s
okay you know you ought to get your
decades in order here that was the 1970s
and the development of all a hoe
Weinberger and Kernighan were the three
people responsible for that we
instituted a rigorous regression test
for all the features walk any of the
three of us who put in a new feature
into the language first had to write a
test for the new feature but what I am
trying to make a point about here is
that as in common with many ideas that
become popular There is obviously an
original vision that a few people share
it is crystal clear it is obvious it is
normally complete and fully formed we
see this with microservices we see this
with agile we've seen this with object
orientation we're seeing the functional
programming and yes also for procedural
programming as well as I want to make
the case here I've talked about other
paradigms and I thought it's time to
give procedural programming a little bit
of love and to shine the light on it
let's talk about testing a bit more
because we can actually see a few other
things here going back to the 1960s Alan
Perlis also said there's no such
question as testing things after the
fact with simulation models but that in
effect the testing and the replacement
of simulations with modules that a
deeper and more detail goes on with the
simulation model controlling as it were
the place and order in which these
things aren't done if you're struggling
to pass that let me just replace that
with mock objects which were invented by
archway tube station in London in 1999
or in 1968 at a meeting obviously they
did not have the
the detail or the insight to elaborate
the details but the the germ of the idea
was already there
this idea of Perpetual elaboration I'm
gonna dummy something and then elaborate
it but also there's something here we're
gonna talk about mock objects then
perhaps we should talk about objects it
turns out the psychotherapist so that
here's a lot of objects psychotherapists
are utterly obsessed with objects
actually they're asked to be obsessed
who's my experience but what I want to
refer to here is we got objects we've
got a stack Oh everybody loves a good
stack so let's put a good stack up here
the word similar simulation came into
that previous thing here we go this is
similar 67 code and obviously the clue
to the languages age is in its number so
it's 50 this year and we find a number
of things here I haven't put any virtual
procedures in here but virtual comes
from similar this comes from similar if
you're using any of those languages that
use these keywords this is where it all
comes from and so I've got a very simple
snack here and you know we can see all
the basic bits and pieces are already in
place but where did Simula get its ideas
from similar 67 was an extension of
Algol 60 it was described by many as an
improvement on many of his successes
okay there are ideas in there that we
can still mine but there's something in
the heart of similar that goes right
back to procedural thinking now this is
the 1960s so what are we got we've got
procedural thinking that's where that's
assumed where a lot of people are still
programming assembler people are not
necessarily taking the Algol path
because Algol was primarily European
initiative but Fortran for which John
Backus why he didn't exactly later
apologize but you know he came up with
good stuff later in his life and COBOL
were driven by large companies in this
case IBM and naturally grabbed the mind
share but there were ideas around and
not everything that was around was
necessarily going to become popular at
that point we see also this is the era
of early Lisp
the list manual was the early 60s
although the languages effectively
invented in the late 50s I think it's
one of the best written examples of how
to introduce a language because they
introduced it with the implementation I
thought it was absolutely brilliant
because you couldn't port stuff you know
there's no concept of open source or
anything like that so we're going to
tell you how to build a list machine
whilst we teach you Lisp and it's very
cool so there's a lot of stuff know so
this is the 1960s what do we got
we've got procedural programming we've
got object-oriented programming we got
functional programming yeah things have
really changed in the last 50 years
haven't they a slight where we've moved
all this way and we are exactly back
where we started
well not exactly we have a better
understanding we've tried stuff out but
basically everything that we now do or
the majority of what we now have do was
already in play in some form so I
mentioned earlier on that there was a
kind of idea procedural programming when
we think about it we think about its
organizing principle this is the
language of structured programming
structured programming kind of kicked
off in the late 60s and dominated
people's thinking for their own
discussions in the 1970s this is my copy
of I collect old books in case you're
wondering and I like photographing them
as well
they're a lot easier to photograph than
people so this is my copy of structure
program early Johann Dahl let's go
Dijkstra and Tony Hall Dahl was one of
the co-inventors of simular 67 and
people think they understand what
structured programming is but this is a
collection of essays from the 1960s and
early 70s when you dig into it there's
some really interesting stuff some of it
is a little dated some of it is still
ahead of its time and some of it is oh
that's where this idea came from and
people often think however when they
talk about structured programming they
have a simplified view the structured
programming is not just all about the
go-to yeah this is the classic problem
when an idea becomes popular it becomes
simplified in some we're guns diluted
every we said this whole paradigm is
about that yeah I've had conversations
with people about objects and they're
there they're going like yeah but
where's the manager
object it's like no really it's not
about that yeah in fact it's almost
exactly not about that yeah so we end up
you see it and by the way in the heart
of go to there's okay that's just a
coincidence actually there's a little
bit more to this we'll come back to that
so the thing is when people think about
go to they start thinking of Dijkstra
the classic letter comes the ACM once
again 1968 go-to statement considered
harmful and people this is the launch of
what is known well this is a kind of
standard phrase isn't it
something considered harmful these days
if you want to do anything and you want
to draw attention to itself you use its
standard clickbait it's just like X
considered harmful okay it's just like
yeah I'm gonna write a blog you know how
do I write a blog introduction to
something or other that's really but
yeah it's really boring okay let me
reframe that as something considered
harmful let's find a risk yeah that
suddenly you get all the you your
webpage you're getting the hits now
fantastic okay this is effectively what
is known there was actually term for
this now one of the things that one
things that I do is I have a page on
Facebook called word Friday where I
share an unusual word every Friday and
the rest of the week is linguistics and
words and other stuff of interest one of
the words that I came across a few years
ago and put a definition up for was a
snow clone so this is quite a useful
word a snow clone a cliched wording used
as a template typically originating in a
single quote such as X considered
harmful these aren't the X's you're
looking for X is the new Y it's X but
not as we know it next left behind is X
is all the way down all your X are
belong to us these are examples of snow
clothes okay so we might say okay go to
statement consider harmful BIOS code
extra he launched a snow clone actually
he didn't this is the original that he
sent a case against the go-to statement
it's much more modest it's much simpler
it's I'm offering you something here it
turns out that the editor of
communications of the ACM for that issue
was Nicolas birth the inventor of
scale and what what birth did is he
decided well these days we call it
clickbait he changed it you know it's
just that a case against they got no I
need something snappier I need something
that's going to get the hits you know
people are opening up their cons of the
ACM and they going to look down the pit
go to state and considered harmful
excellent and change that so I want to
take this a little bit beyond this but
as an idea this whole go to thing it
still resonates this is the talent guide
to design programs in 1995 they pull no
punches a go to completely invalidates
the high-level structure of the code
there's no kind of doubt about what they
think here what are they saying here a
lot of people have never had the
experience of working with go-to written
code okay maybe if you've done some
assembler you've can counter dit or
maybe you've come across and fairly
treacherous old see my experience was
that I this is my confession to you once
upon a time I programmed Fortran and all
of these discussions were currents then
and the use of go-to and all the rest of
it and yeah goto doesn't have to be
spelt go to go to can be spelt in a
number of different ways when we talk
about the idea of the discipline of
structured programming the discipline of
structured programming is the idea of a
single entry into a block and a single
normal exit you may exit via abnormal
means but a single normal exit and
people often less you talk about the
multiple exit thing but they never
understand what does multiple entry look
like it looks like this this is known as
Duff's device it is a device it is an
approach to unrolling a loop it is used
it was used in the early 80s I believe
in some telecoms code at AT&T it is
astonishing and scary I remember the
first time I saw this is you know this
was a real WTF moment it was just that
you can do this if you want to do this
in Java
you can't the the language designers
decided no c-sharp no you can't do this
there in fact C is pretty much the only
place you can do that
Tom Duff captured his feelings I feel a
combination of Pride and revulsion at
this discovery the ability to jump into
the middle of a block so actually what
we've got if you've ever wondered so
let's let's go back to the 1960s 1960s
was was when Star Trek was first aired
and Star Trek introduced to the the
public the idea of teleport and always
that question what happens when you
teleport into something in the same
place well this is what happens when you
teleport a dowhile loop into a switch
statements they merge in the same place
ok and it's it's a horrible ghastly
thing that is both revolting and elegant
and probably worthy as tom duff says
many people have said that the worst
feature see is that switches don't break
automatically before each case label of
this Co forms some sort of argument in
that debate but I'm not sure whether
it's for or against now the point with
this stuff is there's an idea when we
talk about the organisation of
procedural programming as a discipline
of thinking as discipline of programming
there is an idea here that what is a
block what is a what is a statement the
idea that I can substitute one thing for
another is a very profound idea and it
is about this ID this idea of single
entry single exit is part of it so I've
got a render this I'm gonna bring this
one up this is I think the only piece of
21st century language we're going to
actually include so this is groovy this
is the leap year thing that I showed
earlier on but done done in groovy now
one of the things that groovy allows you
to do is is say ok that last the last
statement in the block doesn't actually
have to have an explicit return we can
basically say that the block comes to
equal that last term so I can easily do
that gets me they Algol 68 code that I
had earlier but some people are not
comfortable with this logic they'd like
to see the if spelt out they don't like
the hands and ORS so they need to go
about it and they do this there's
another way of doing it that also does
ifs and returns and it looks like this
one of these is structured and one of
these is not
one of these is elegant and one of these
is popular this is the most popular one
I find myself always dealing with people
as out yeah yeah but eclipsed maybe do
it and stuff like that
and the point is that the there is a
there is a qualitative difference these
will actually generate the same
underlying code you actually there's no
this is not a question of what you're
generating in terms of the code it's a
jet it's to do with the model of
reasoning that we bring to it and that's
the different thing if we look here if I
try and do the replacement I can only do
it in one place for this one over here
over there every branch there's a tail
return every branch exclusively ends as
the result of the function okay there is
an exclusive path through this and it is
simple in fact I'm gonna put the return
back in there because that just makes it
look uncomfortably irregular if we want
to understand block structure and what
people were actually trying to talk
about it turns out that what they were
talking about was the alignment of
control flow and data flow now if you
frame it like that you get a lot more
people on board because they Collier
yarn totally about the functional and
that it's about the alignment of the
control flow and the data flow but they
didn't articulate it like that because
that language or model of reasoning did
not yet exist but the block idea is
really important people often assume
when these days which I hope we all
indent our code I say I hope because I
don't make that assumption I find a lot
of self-taught programmers that don't
use ideas do not indent their code and
regard that as some personal point of
style you know oh that's just the way I
do it that's my style this notes
unreadable and I mentioned for train
earlier on I I worked on my boss's code
he didn't believe in such nonsense as
you know indentation you know there's an
affectation as far as he was concerned
when I indented his code the number of
bugs I found was astonishing and
frightening but let's get back to this
let's understand the nature of block
structure is the idea of folding
concepts away it's about folding
complexity it is the idea that I can
take I'm gonna just fold away all of the
second-level stuff I'm going to focus on
the first verbal stuff so can I reason
about this function and this function
without on
standing the content of each branch and
the answer is now in one case and yes in
the other on the right hand side I have
something that is visually honest it
says this is a function that is a
four-way decision and does it look like
it absolutely okay mutually exclusive
parts on the left hand side I've got
surprise as a mystery obviously not in a
piece of code this long I'm gonna say
this is a non-challenging piece of code
almost anywhere you write it but it's
when it gets larger that we struggle the
point here is that what is going on on
the left-hand side if I on the left-hand
side this is either will get a return
false but we've got a bunch of guard
statements to check for bad cases these
are not bad cases this is the definition
of a leap year it's perfectly good these
are not exception these are not guard
clauses there's some misuse of the guard
Clause idea or it's we're going to
return false but we've got three
optional pieces of pre-processing to do
is that what we know the point here is
you cannot tell unless you go into the
next level the idea of a block and
procedural programming is to encapsulate
a bunch of stuff so you don't need to
know what it does I don't need to know
that there are returns in there
continues in there in fact I can put
anything I like in that and it won't
change on this side that is the basic
idea
they were stroke that is what we mean by
this stuff so we put the stuff back and
turns out that this is this is the one
that we want to focus on that's what we
mean by structured programming and as
they observe one of the most powerful
mechanisms for program structuring is
the block and procedure concept now this
it turns out is where a lot of ideas
stem from there's this simple idea that
when we are organizing you've got messy
procedural and tidy procedural the
structured view was to compose any logic
to describe what it is that you need to
do all you need is sequence so
sequential composition I have one thing
and then another I need to be able to
make a decision I need to select between
alternatives and I need iteration
if you place it eration with named
abstraction you can get rid of iteration
and have recursion but the idea here is
the let us not assume that that is
available to us secret selection
iteration and this was proven to be
basically all you needed and what you
did is you organized your codebase
according to this then over a series of
procedures now if we look at a
characterization of this is an
architecture in in Basque clams and
Casman software architecture and
practice they refer to this style as
main program and subroutine I've never
met a programmer who has referred to
this style as main program and
subroutine I think sometimes I think
it's a really good characterization that
they describe but sometimes people
struggle for names what do we call this
procedural approach we could call it
procedural no no no that's too obvious
let's describe it by what it's know at
some point we're going to have lunch
oh okay does that mean first course
second course and dessert no no we don't
describe like that we call it lunch okay
so there is a notion here that there's
also the fact that people didn't think
of this as a programming style because
everybody was doing it this was the main
stream of programming yeah if
everybody's doing it you don't have a
name for the style you know what what's
the deal what's your programming style
its programming style it's the way we
program but what does have a name yes
it's called programming you know what
are you talking about yeah if you went
to most mainstream programmers back in
70s and 80s there was no concept of
alternatives here okay regardless of the
naming we understand it's accurate if a
little long-winded they characterize
this architectural style the goal is to
decompose a program into smaller pieces
to help achieve modify ability yeah I'm
not aware of any architectural style it
doesn't have this as its mandate so this
is kind of noise you know you don't get
people saying we can't with a new
paradigm the idea here is to cause
problems for maintainability or to not
allow you to decompose that's not how
people do at work okay so that's a noise
statement this is more meaningful this
is the vision so I'm not going to say
that procedural programming is what you
want to do everywhere but if your
problem looks like this then this is the
way to start think
about it the idea is that we have many
paradigms because problems have many
shapes a problem is decomposed
hierarchically each paradigm that you
encounter has a philosophy it says here
is a truth that we hold for this kind of
thing and this is what we're going to do
we're going to decompose things
hierarchically okay there you go main
program subroutine that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna p8 a tree of
control a tree of decomposition top-down
programming stepwise refinement these
are all terms about how we organize this
we have an objective that the code wants
to achieve you can see this doesn't
necessarily work for event-driven code
great we've already discovered now a
style that it doesn't work for but if
you have an objective and you can
decompose it algorithmically is quite a
good one then you've got this and it
goes deeper than this the structured
programming school they actually there
was actually a way of characterizing
these things it wasn't just about throws
subroutines together people came up with
wonderful names for stuff there's a
whole vocabulary for this this is the
afferent branch the transform branch the
efferent branch let me read that these
are good these are good terms to throw
into a conversation if you want to
confuse your colleagues you know if you
want to kind of you know sister oh yeah
but I was looking down the the efferent
branch of the code I think he means
output input process output okay well
we've never seen that before
yeah but that's too obvious again we
have to come up with names that confuse
people you can't call out the input the
process and the output branch because
then the people know what you're talking
about so what we're gonna have is the
afferent transform and efferent brush
yeah we're gonna raise it a bit yeah
make it sound more computer science see
now obviously we don't always call it
you know so we see this philosophically
and then we see further characterization
here this tells us a little bit more
about what is it that makes procedural
procedural there's typically a single
thread of control that will come back to
haunt us and each component in the
hierarchy gets this control so it's the
passing of control and in the structure
world we view that with respect to
selection at sequence selection and
iteration the passing of control
optionally along with some data from its
parent and passes it along to its
children we have a strict stacked
to plan for how control and data flow to
and fro throughout the codebase through
this hierarchical decomposition yes a so
subroutine perhaps we don't use that
term anymore as much maybe we call it
procedure maybe we call it function mmm
curious if I took away mutable state
from procedural what would I be left
with what's it called functional
programming yeah if you take away the
mutable state and you still have you can
still pass procedures around you have
higher-order procedures and now let's
recall them higher-order functions and
so on that's the thought ah this was all
there oh that's interesting what I find
interesting
what validates or strengthens the
paradigm is when you can arrive at its
conclusions from multiple paths it's not
just one way of thinking it's like you
can reach a functional view of the world
as you can reach an object view of the
world by taking many different roads and
it's just that same conclusion that
validates it in that sense now of course
this beauty of this hierarchy is that of
course it doesn't look like this in real
programs you end up with mixing of
levels okay you end up with fan-in and
fan-out
fan-in what would we call that we call
that reuse okay here's the thing I've
used it in more than one place okay
fan-out that's classic decomposition or
approach and also we get recursion
direct recursion and mutual recursion so
yeah this the trees looking a bit messy
and this does also tell us that there is
a limitation sometimes to how we think
about things as Tony Hoare observed you
cannot teach beginners top-down
programming because they don't know
which end is up
and I think that is wonderful because
the idea is when I'm trying to establish
what is the objective and goal of this
program you know what that is
non-trivial we've created whole
methodologies to try and answer that
question what do we mean by this / let's
also have this wonderful observations
everything should be built top-down
except the first time I think it's a
lovely way of putting it it turns out
the top-down is a great way of
describing something it's entirely
reasonable you can actually show
somebody in decompose an idea top
but that may not be the same as the
story that was used to create it yeah
but it's a great way of describing it
because people go hell yeah yeah yeah
yeah why did they take so long to
develop it's so obvious now they said it
that's how you know you've got something
really good top down is a great
description model so this presents us
with a bit of a challenge
how shall we organize our procedures
into the breech steps David Parnas 1972
what else happened in 1972 Apollo 18
never left the launch pad
there was no Apollo 18 Apollo 17 was the
last one and and so that's the end of
the moon landing story but the beginning
of modularity yeah right we proposed
that one begins with a list of difficult
design decisions or design decisions
which are likely to change now here's an
interesting question how do you know
this one hasn't changed okay this is
1972 45 years ago how do you know that
something is a difficult design decision
well I don't know we keep spending hours
discussing it there you go we can't
agree on something there you go yeah the
fact that you cannot agree with your
colleagues about something is a really
strong big arrow saying we're not sure
about this it is not an opportunity for
you to beat your colleague or come up
with the killer answer is an opportunity
to step back and go that's interesting
maybe the answer is not so obvious maybe
there are multiple ways maybe the way
that we describe it now is good in one
way but in six months the world moves on
the frameworks moves on the performance
requirements move on and we have to
change somewhere else so let's structure
our code according to this level of
indecision each module is then designed
designed to hide such a decision from
the others and that is a kind of a
classic way of thinking this was the
overlay on two classic procedural
programming this idea of modules and
modular programming sort of came along
again it did not get adopted into the
mainstream as readily or as comfortable
as people would have hoped
and indeed the mainstay of programming
in the 70s something like Fortran did
eventually get modules but it wasn't
until the 1990s that it did so it was
never one to hurry things
but one of the most common decisions
that we can make concerns data
structuring Barbara Liskov recipient of
the cheering award in 2009 she was one
of the key individuals this is 1974 key
individuals and really motivating a
style of programming organized around
data types but not simply structured
data but abstract data abstract data
types
defines a class of abstract objects
which is completely characterized by the
operations available on those objects a
programmer is concerned only with the
behavior which that objects exhibits but
not with any details of how the behavior
is achieved by means of the
implementation implementation like yep
there we go 1974 again what happened in
1974 the outlaw 68 report was finished
again people weren't doing much
interesting stuff in space on the other
side of the Atlantic but the Soviet
Union was doing some very interesting
stuff and there's a whole lot of stuff
that was going on in code this was
really quite exciting now what else
happened the 1970s see happened in the
1970s so it turns out you can actually
mix this approach in with C so let's go
back to our stack of books I'll just
have it as a snack of strings let's
update this to ANSI C and what I've got
here is a forward declaration of a thing
called a stack okay and a regularization
of the name and how is that going to
look well we're going to create a stack
and we're going to be able to delete a
stack okay notice there's no detail of
what a stack looks like the idea is that
I've simply said let's talk about how
you work with the stack don't worry
about the details this isn't a header
file and here are the common operations
there's going to be a stack of strings
so const char star I'm going to push I'm
going to pop it's a pure pop I'm not
returning anything from that depth I can
query that and I can also find out the
top element and we're also going to
allow people to link this in to and and
compile this into their C++ code so we
put a bit of noise in okay so what is
the implementation look like I'm not
going to focus on the implementation I
just want to show you what it looks like
there we go so here's an implementation
very simple implementation of that
protocol but I can also change the
implementation that's implemented in C
what flavor of C that is definitely C 89
it's the 89 90 depending on how you want
to count yeah it's not it's not later
and this is C++ so I've got exactly the
same I've got exactly the same interface
it passes exactly the same tests but
I've not only have I got a slightly
different implementation I've ended up
using a different language that is what
was meant by abstract data types it's
that abstract you can change the
language but you're still focusing on
something that is how do I do this
however there is a small difference
between these pieces of code and it is
to do with memory ownership and this is
a struggle and a lot of people think
okay procedural programming that means
you're always going to manage your own
memory these two are different the C
version leaves the question of memory
management's slightly open the C++
version encapsulate sit so I've talked
about the 1960s I talked about 70s and
Beyond I want to go back a little bit
further okay
Shakespeare was one of the first
programmers that I know of in England
and he had a bit of a problem there
weren't any computers it makes it really
difficult to program things when there
are no computers and the Elizabeth near
the the late 16th and early 17th century
there was a lack of computers however
Shakespeare was a big fan of the actor
theory so he used actors to do this
again centuries ahead of the centuries
ahead of time but he had to encode his
concepts and his models of programming
carefully into his place and when you
review his plays with this in mind you
end up with a completely different world
view so for example and Hamlet the
tragedy of Hamlet Prince of Denmark is
actually a play about memory management
we can see it from one of its most
famous lines to be or not to be that is
the question
you see Shakespeare is vexed by this
question this is difficult how are we
going to manage the memory now we've got
a philia steps in and
as tis in my memory locked and you
yourself shall keep the key of it o
philia a feeder is really big on malloc
and free new and delete she says okay
you manage your own memory you know I
trust you with this one that did not
work out well
Hamlet's a little more you know ah you
know what I think garbage collection
what about that
yay from the table of my memory I'll
wipe away all trivial fond records okay
so we see here that this has been
playing people as a problem for a very
long time encapsulated with non accounts
today two explicit memory management
versus the idea of garbage collection or
something that is managed and there is a
thought that sometimes people again if I
said associate procedural programming
with the the unmanaged approach but I'm
going to say that that is purely
historical or rather a one view of
history Algol 68 had garbage collection
Simula 67 had garbage collection these
are 1960s languages and one at the time
people assumed that it was only lisp had
it no no garbage collection was a thing
the problem is we did not have the
resources available to make a good go of
it for anything other than academic
programming people that the point is
that at that point to try and introduce
this into limited memory limited
processing environments was seen as a
luxury if we revisit procedural
programming from that point of view and
we see actually yeah we could do this
and we do do this because this is where
it gets kind of interesting the there is
idea that when we look at this there's
another concept that is that is going on
how old is whether why do i how old is
this idea of capturing state and moving
it around how old is this idea of
organizing your code with units of state
associated with procedures well it turns
out that part of structured programming
part of the procedural paradigm as it
was envisaged included a rather
interesting idea called hierarchical
program structures a procedure which is
capable of giving rise to block
instances which survive its call
we'll be known as a class and the
instances will be known as objects of
that class so there is this idea that
the block and procedure concept is the
powerful idea what if I were to pass to
you a block that contained data and its
own procedures again we can call that a
closure we can call that we can say that
there's a lambda nurse happening there's
all kinds of stuff here that was the
essence of this in fact I can even
represent that in JavaScript I can say
okay I'm going to create a new stack I'm
gonna have a private representation it's
so private you can't even reflect on it
its proper private because it's a local
variable items it's gonna be an array
and then I'm going to return to you a
collection basically of named lambdas
depth top pot and push that operate on
that and so what you are given is
something that is truly a separation of
implementation from the public face you
are only presented with something
through which you can name methods this
is effectively a realization of that
block idea this is that one of the
purest forms of object orientation that
you can have and we can mess about with
implementation and still get get it
passing the same tests now there's
another thing people associate with
object orientation and it's it's it's
known as concatenation well it is the
dessert it's called inheritance but back
then it wasn't called inheritance
it's called concatenation the idea that
I can concatenate one block with another
and that they end up with the merger of
all of the procedures and all of the
state together was the basis of
inheritance concatenation is an
operation to find between two classes a
B or a class and a block you can have a
free-standing block and just inherit
into that block mixin style and results
in the formation of a new class or block
actually we can do that with the is that
this idea here concatenation is a
merging of attributes and composition of
their actions we can actually show this
if I just tweak my JavaScript code a
little bit and add in the idea of a base
class and add in the quality of
something being stackable and then add
in the idea that you add things you can
catenate onto the existing base you add
in new methods
okay what does that look like if we do
inheritance or other concatenation I'm
going to take an empty object that does
nothing I'm going to make it stackable
so that's how I create a new stack okay
let's make it clear about so we can
actually clear all the elements of the
stack as well
what's that look like well that's
clearable stackable okay so we've
actually got inheritance is an act of
composition okay this is a it turns out
that it's a fundamental concept here and
we can actually make it a true
composition in the functional style with
a reduction so now means inheritance is
equivalent to composition which is quite
cute and encapsulation is equivalent to
passing a block so here's another old
idea the construction principle concept
hierarchies is called abstractions we
concentrate on features common to many
phenomena and we abstract away features
too far removed from the level we're
working at so here's an interesting idea
this is all part of the structured
programming vision of how you work with
procedural programming this is the bit
that people forgot it's the third part
of the book the book has three parts
everybody focuses on the first part
which is about control flow the second
part is on data structuring the third
part is this okay and what we discover
is that people's view of structure
programming and the is the organizing
discipline for procedural is incredibly
narrow from a historical point of view
so hang on if we're talking about
concept hierarchies that leads to type
hierarchies substitutability Barbara
Liskov again for whom the Liskov
substitution principle is named and she
described this type hierarchy is
composed of sub types of super types the
intuitive idea of a sub type is one
whose objects provide all the behavior
of objects of another type plus
something extra and then she
characterizes this what is wanted is a
property here substitution if for each
object oh one of type s there at that I
see it in action let's have a non
duplicate top let's mix in a non
duplicate top let us imagine that we
have we want to make our stack so if you
add in a duplicate top then it doesn't
add it okay
so if you add in the same element twice
it says ah we're not going to have it
okay so let's just add that in let's mix
I'm gonna mix that in I'm gonna write
simple tests here and the test is a
non-empty snap becomes deeper by
retaining a
item as it stop we're going to create a
new stack I'm gonna push build stuff and
then we push 2017 we're going to push
2017 so we're gonna push 2017 twice the
debt should be three the top element
should be 2017 okay if I make the stack
if I make a stack if I compose a
clearable stackable object then this
passes if I then make it a non-duplicate
top this fails in other words it turns
out that the Liskov substitution
principle is an extension of concept
hierarchies what Barbara Atlas kapha was
poking us focusing on was this it's a
test of a property for all programs P
defined in terms of T the behavior of P
is unchanged when oh one is substituted
for o2 now that's not the 1960s this is
the 1980s but what we see is that
flowing from that original vision of
we're going to organize procedures and
were going to allow concatenation
between blocks in a way that allows you
to organize concepts based on
abstraction we see all of these ideas
coming together but I want to talk a
little bit I want to end the talk by say
okay this is all very well this is
historical but what does that mean for
the present tense well first of all it
means that these ideas are old they are
testable they've been around most of the
things that you're seeing in programming
languages already probably existed and
that's okay let's take a different view
let's understand what is the future of
procedural programmed because it turns
out that procedural programming is still
one of the dominant approaches not
always kirat applied correctly that's
why people use the term procedural to
mean that it's a long way of saying that
when people say oh that code it's so
procedural they're not saying nice
things about it okay because it's been
applied out of its context where it
tells you that it's got a problem with
context and there is a different vision
I want to offer you this idea I
mentioned earlier on this multi-paradigm
approach the idea that procedural is
perhaps very good at describing things
that are small it's not always the right
thing there's lots of other things that
are good at describing things that are
small but what you need is a separation
and David galantin who was one of the
key developers of the Linder system
talks about coordination languages this
is a from 1992 we can build a complete
programming model out of two separate
pieces
the computation model and the
coordination model and this is something
that we have been moving towards and
where we can see future of mixed
paradigms including procedural I'm going
historically we had Nicolas worth
writing this is the title of a book that
he wrote on structure programming
algorithms plus data structures equals
programs we are going to refine this
coordination plus computation equals
programs and we see that this idea has
been around for a very long time this is
the original make program on make the
bank build system if you look at make
make is a declarative system as observed
here the make file language is similar
to declarative programming its main
backbone its coordination model is
declarative you set an objective
relationships between files and then the
computation model is procedural it's
regular script so in other words it acts
as a framework in which to hang your
scripting code and of course this can be
if you've always assumed that state
change was okay and sequencing was
always guaranteed this is going to
confuse you because if this is the
imperative model that we're coming into
conflict with but this vision of
something bigger actually gives us a
very different way of looking at things
like concurrency so let's understand I
mentioned earlier on there was a there
was a limited there was a problem with
this idea of single thread of control I
want to present to you food for thought
given that it's lunch food for thought
this is a simple quadrant diagram that
characterizes what you need how you need
to think of sharing of data with respect
to concurrency you your data can be
mutable or immutable and you can have it
shared or not shared there are four
quadrants okay one of them is difficult
I'm going to use I'm going to use
nature's color of danger to give you a
clue here okay the color of blood blood
is on your code okay this is the hard
bit this is this
synchronization quadrant if your data is
mutable and shared between threads you
will have a hard time if it is immutable
you will have an easy time if it is
unshared you will have an easy time but
when the minute you share it and change
it you will have a hard time but we are
drawn like moths to a flame to the top
right-hand quadrant 3/4 of it looks easy
ah that's too easy let's move there but
why did we end up here
unfortunately ended up here because of
procedural because procedural procedural
soft space its comfort zone is a very
simple idea the world is sequential
sequence selection iteration we do that
that means we're on the left-hand side
the decades we were on the left-hand
side and it was a matter of constraint
and efficiency that we're on the
left-hand side and we favored the
mutable model that's closest to us
closest to the machine so when threads
come along we find ourselves moving
right words and we go from the top left
to the top right which is where all the
pain happens I was like David butan
Hoffs observation about mutexes I've
often joke that instead of picking up
Dijkstra's cue acronym we should have
called the basic synchronization object
the bottleneck yeah I want you to think
about that conversationally what you
need here in this code is a bottleneck
yeah it doesn't sound quite so good
mutex makes it sound kind of like
positive and computer sciences it's like
oh we need a bottleneck here mm-hmm it's
so good so we actually find the original
vision computation model allows programs
to build a single computational activity
a single threaded step at a time
computation that is the idea is what you
have is little pieces of computation and
then you coordinate this idea of
coordination language is you know the
model allows you to create a larger
ensemble and one of the earliest
examples we have of this dates back to
1964 Doug McIlroy again we should have
some way of coupling programs like
garden hoses screw in another segment
when it becomes necessary to massage the
data in another way this is the
invention of the UNIX pipeline it took
another six years to pick the character
okay 1970 Ken Thompson did that but this
is the basic data flow architecture this
is the coordination model
for eunuchs okay the classic eunuchs
model is we have procedural she'll and
procedural see code and then we have a
coordination model that is the pipeline
we can extend the pipeline we can do
lots of things we can talk about
pipelines as a discipline we can say
what you have perhaps a number of items
you can keep in there so whether it's
bounded its buffered it's asynchronous
so the all these ideas are fundamental a
we can change the numbers you can have
infinite well you can't but you know
unbounded don't have unbounded probe
using your code it's bad but unbounded
buffered an asynchronous if you make it
one it's bounded buffered in a
synchronous we call that a future
futures and promises come out of this
model and if you make it zero you end up
with the channel the default channel
model of go and other languages that use
this like akhom and indeed a classic
coordination model this is how this was
one of the ways of reasoning about all
of this Tony Hoare again communicating
sequential processes we take sequential
processes because it turns out we're
really good with sequence and we
coordinate between them using channels
this is 1970s okay the book was 80 but
the original CSP model was 1970s people
have come to the actor model which
relates to this and CSP again recently
this idea of paradigm mixing through
coordination and computation makes sense
of where procedural programming is going
to be with us in years to come so on
that now if you're going to use the word
paradigm I always direct people to this
paper this is that's a deep sound
paradigms program Robert Floyd cheering
Award winner in 1979 he's the guy we can
blame for using the word paradigm and
introducing it to software developers
and his perspective was not that we
should pick the best paradigm he had a
very different view I believe the
current state of the art of computer
programming reflects inadequacies in our
stalker paradigms on knowledge of
existing paradigms in the way we teach
programming paradigms and in the way our
programming languages support will fail
to support the paradigms of their user
communities this was true in 1979 I want
to
it is still true now so that I would
urge you to go back and revisit the
basic ingredients of something like
procedural programming or a paradigm
that you learnt and rejected and
forgotten decided this is ridiculous so
this is an old idea this is a deep idea
and this is how we're going to be taking
this forward I hope that's been useful
or at least provocative thank you very
much